welcome to this video I hope this is
working alright trying to do this with
my phone here okay this is a little bit
different obviously i'm just showing
yourself some pictures from Wham being
at the moment on vacation on a
three-week vacation first them a couple
of days in slovenia that in austria I'll
be relaxing mostly but playing a
tournament at the end of the vacation
the last week we'll have a tournament in
Austria and I will be covering that also
when I return which will be mid august
august i think 18th or 19th i'll be back
and back then also my channel will have
much more content at the moment i only
have the Blitz videos on while I'm away
I've recorded this before I left but I
don't do anything during my vacation
it's a real vacation so I won't cover
the olympiad or any other event yeah ok
this is just a small message to tell you
that you only have the Blitz videos in
the next two and a half weeks but i'll
be back with much more content something
about my my own tournament but also
something about yea general chess
educational content that will be a
regular feature on the channel so look
forward to that starting mid august
thanks and bye